>> Greg: HI, I’M GREG GUTFELD,
JESSE WATTERS, DANA PERINO,
JUAN WILLIAMS, "THE FIVE."
WELL, THAT’S OVER WITH.
FOR NOW.
SO YOU’VE HEARD THE DEFINITION
OF CRAZY, DOING THE SAME THING
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
EXPECTING A DIFFERENT RESULT?
THE DEMOCRATS INVENTED A NEW
KIND OF CRAZY, KNOWING THE
OUTCOME OF AN EVENT WELL IN
ADVANCE AND STILL EXPECTING A
DIFFERENT RESULT.
THAT IS IMPEACHMENT.
THE WORST PLANNED ADVENTURE
SINCE THE DONNER PARTY.
THE DEMS BLEW ALL THEIR ENERGY
ON THE LOSERS BAT, ONE THAT MADE
THE LOSERS POSSIBLE.
THEY FELL FLAT ON THEIR FACES
BECAUSE THEY WERE DISTRACTED.
RETURN TO GREG’S RULE,
REPUBLICANS RUN THINGS,
DEMOCRATS RUIN THINGS.
THE DIFFERENCE IS ONE LETTER,
WHICH STANDS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
ONCE AGAIN THEY RETURNED TO
THEIR HALLUCINATIONS.
THE SNAKES ON THE WALL ARE REAL
IF YOU ARE ADAM SCHIFF BECAUSE
NOW TRUMP COULD OFFER ALASKA TO
THE RUSSIANS.
>> TRUMP COULD OFFER ALASKA TO
THE RUSSIANS IN EXCHANGE FOR
HELP IN THE NEXT ELECTION.
>> Greg: ADAM IS SO NUTTY HE
IS LIKE A TRAIL MIX.
BUT IT BEATS MOVING TO
MAR-A-LAGO.
>> OR DECIDE TO MOVE TO
MAR-A-LAGO PERMANENTLY AND LET
JARED KUSHNER RUN THE COUNTRY.
>> Greg: WHY CLAIM TO MAKE
THESE PREDICTIONS?
BECAUSE THEY DON’T EXIST WHICH
MEANS YOU CAN’T APPROVE THEM
WHICH MEANS, YOU JUST WAIT.
THEY ARE IMAGINARY MICE.
THOSE MAD RAVINGS HAD US WAITING
FOR THE STOCK MARKET CRASH, A
TEAR IN IT, WORLD WAR III,
WORLD WAR IV AND WORLD WERE
FIVE.
INSTEAD ALL WE GOT OUR STOCK
MARKET HIGHS, TRADE DEALS,
TARIFFS, AND SINCE THOSE
SUCCESSES ARE UNDER TRUMP, THE
DELUSIONS ONLY DEEPEN.
WITHOUT A REAL VISION THEY CLING
TO THESE MENTAL PHANTOMS.
EARLY ON, WE TOLD THE DEMOCRATS,
IMPEACHMENT WAS A DEAD FISH.
DON’T FOLLOW ADAM, HE IS SELLING
YOU DRUGS THAT ONLY END IN BAD
TRIPS.
BUT DID THEY LISTEN?
NO.
TO THEM, BAD DRUGS ARE BETTER
THAN NO DRUGS, WHICH IS WHY THEY
WILL BE BACK AT THE LAB COMING
UP WITH THE NEW PARANOIA PILL.
BUT WE KNOW NOT TO GULP THEM.
LET THEM HAVE THEM ALL BECAUSE
WE SAW IT COMING BUT THEY HAVE
IT COMING.
ALL RIGHT, WHERE TO START?
JESSE, BIG FAT WASTE OF TIME.
THE ONLY WINNER IN THIS WHOLE
THING, US.
THE NETWORK IS PULLING IN
MILLIONS OF EYEBALLS.
GOD KNOWS WHAT THE AD MONEY IS.
>> Jesse: IT’S A LOT.
>> Greg: MY SECOND HOME IS
BUYING A THIRD HOME.
>> Jesse: AND I DON’T EVEN
HAVE A SECOND HOME.
>> Greg: I HAVE A FOURTH HOME
ON TOP OF MY THIRD HOME.
>> Jesse: STOP BRAGGING, I’M
REALLY JEALOUS.
>> Greg: MY SIX HOME IS DATING
MY SEVENTH HOME.
>> Jesse: WHEN I AM YOUR AGE
MAY BE I WILL HAVE A SECOND
HOME.
>> Dana: OH, VERY GOOD.
WHEN I GOT ON SET, JUAN WILLIAMS
ASKED, ARE YOU PUMPED ABOUT THE
ACQUITTAL?
AND I SAID, WE KNEW THIS WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
THIS IS LIKE WHEN YOUR WIFE OR
HUSBAND MAKES YOU GO OUT TO
DINNER TO ANOTHER COUPLE’S HOUSE
WHO YOU HATE.
YOU HAVE TO GO.
THEIR FOOD IS TERRIBLE, YOU KNOW
YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE A BAD TIME.
EVENTUALLY IT’S GOING TO BE OVER
AND YOU’RE GOING TO BE BACK IN
BED IN ARE GOING TO SAY, I TOLD
YOU, HONEY.
>> Dana: WAS THAT THE ONE AT
MY HOUSE?
>> Jesse: YES, IT WAS!
>> Greg: HE’S TALKING ABOUT
THE QUESO NIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: JUST TO SAY
SOMETHING, TO HAVE A TRUMP
IMPEACHMENT, YOU DON’T HAVE A
DEAD BODY, YOU DON’T HAVE A
SUITCASE FULL OF CASH IN HER
FREEZER.
THIS IS THE LAMEST IMPEACHMENT
EVER.
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT WHAT YOU
SAID IN THE MONOLOGUE, THESE
CRAZY PREDICTIONS, IT’S THE SAME
THING WITH GLOBAL WARMING.
IN 20 YEARS, MIAMI IS GOING TO
BE UNDERWATER AND IF YOU SAY, I
DON’T THINK THAT IS POSSIBLE,
THEY SAY, OH, YOU’VE GOT TO
BELIEVE ME.
BY THE WAY, YOU GOT TO GIVE ME
ALL YOUR MONEY.
THAT IS THE SAME THING.
IT’S A STICKUP SCAM.
I DIDN’T FALL FOR IT BECAUSE I
TOLD YOU THE WHOLE TIME WHAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
HE DIDN’T LISTEN, JUAN.
ARE YOU HAPPY, JUAN?
BECAUSE IT BACKFIRED.
>> Juan: WHY DO YOU SAY IT
BACKFIRED?
>> Jesse: BECAUSE BIDEN GOT
DAMAGED, YOU’RE NOT GOING TO
RETAKE THE SENATE, TRUMP IS AT
49% APPROVAL AND WHAT DID WE
LEARN?
THERE IS A PHONE CALL AND THE
TRANSCRIPTS CAME OUT.
I LEARNED I WAS RIGHT BUT I KNEW
THAT BEFORE HAND.
>> Juan: RIGHT, YOU’RE ALWAYS
RIGHT.
BUT I WILL SAY I THINK
IMPEACHMENT LED MOST OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE NOW TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A
CORRUPT PRESIDENT.
BUT THEY SAID IN ESSENCE AND
THIS WAS THE REPUBLICAN LINE,
EVEN IF HE DID IT, WE DON’T
THINK IT IS QUITE IMPEACHABLE.
WAIT UNTIL THE ELECTION, AS IF
THE FOREFATHERS DIDN’T THINK
ABOUT ELECTIONS.
I’M GOING TO GIVE YOU A FEW
SENATORS, SENATOR RUBIO,
SENATOR MURKOWSKI AND OF COURSE
SENATOR ROMNEY, WHO VOTED TO
CONVICT.
ALL SAYING THE PRESIDENT DID
SOMETHING WRONG, EMBARRASSING,
INAPPROPRIATE, ALL OF IT.
>> Greg: WE SAW THAT TRUTH.
THE TRICK.
YOU JUST GROUPED ROMNEY WITH
PEOPLE WHO DIDN’T VOTE TO
IMPEACH.
>> Juan: NO, I’M JUST TELLING
YOU THAT’S WHAT THEY SAID.
THEY SAID THE MANAGER IS MADE A
CONVINCING CASE BUT THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO CONVICT.
I THINK ROMNEY SHOULD BE HONORED
AS A MAN OF PRINCIPLE IN THIS
CASE BECAUSE AT LEAST HE VOTED
WITH HIS HEART AND NOT ABOUT
POWER OR AVOIDING TRUMP’S
TWEETS.
TO ME, WHAT YOU GET HERE IS THIS
IS WHAT REPUBLICANS IN THE
SENATE SAY, THEY JUST SAY, YOU
KNOW WHAT, BOY, WE DON’T WANT
DONALD TRUMP SAYING NASTY THINGS
ABOUT US.
>> Greg: GOOD MIND-READING,
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE ALL
THINKING.
>> I WAS A LITTLE SURPRISED WITH
THE VOTE WITH JOE MANCHIN, I
THOUGHT HE WOULD MAYBE VOTE TO
ACQUIT THE PRESIDENT ON AT
LEAST ONE OF THE ARTICLES,
CONSIDERING IN WEST VIRGINIA THE
PRESIDENT IS VERY POPULAR AND IT
WOULD’VE BEEN POLITICALLY SAFE
FOR HIM TO DO SO BUT HE VOTED
WITH DEMOCRATS.
A BIPARTISAN ACQUITTAL.
IT DID NOT END UP BEING THAT WAY
BUT THERE IS OBVIOUSLY GOING TO
BE A LOT MADE OF MITT ROMNEY’S
VOTE.
I DON’T THINK IT REALLY MATTERS
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT HAS A 95%
APPROVAL IN THE G.O.P.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE GIVEN
HIM AN APPROVAL RATING AT THE
HIGHEST HE HAS SEEN THROUGHOUT
HIS PRESIDENCY.
THROUGHOUT THE TRIAL ADAM SCHIFF
IS SAYING HE IS GOING TO CHEAT
AND STEAL AND THAT YOU CAN’T
TRUST THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
MAKE DECISIONS IN THE NEXT
ELECTION.
I THINK PEOPLE PROBABLY TOOK
THAT PRETTY PERSONALLY.
MOVING FORWARD, I DON’T THINK IS
ABOUT REALLY MATTERS WHEN IT
COMES TO THE NUMBERS IN THE
PRESIDENT HAS HAD A LOT OF WINS
AND AS SOON AS MITT ROMNEY DOES
SOMETHING THE DEMOCRATS
DISAPPROVE OF HE WILL NO LONGER
BE THE MORAL CLARITY THEY ARE
CLAIMING TODAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO GO BACK TO THE
ELECTION AGAINST BARACK OBAMA
WHEN THEY WERE CALLING HIM A
RACIST, AN ANIMAL ABUSER AND OF
COURSE HE WAS WAGING A WAR ON
WOMEN.
MAYBE THEY WILL TAKE BACK SOME
OF THOSE THINGS.
>> Greg: THE WOMEN IN THE
BINDER.
WHAT IS ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
DEMOCRATIC FATALISM?
>> Dana: PARTLY -- DID YOU
RIGHT THAT DOWN?
OH.
I HAVEN’T EVEN READ THIS ARTICLE
YET.
IT WAS WRITTEN BY JOHN ELLIS,
I’M SURE IT’S VERY GOOD.
NANCY PELOSI WAS ALSO TELLING
THEM FOR MONTHS, DON’T DO THIS,
IT’S GOING TO BACKFIRE, IT IS
NOT A GOOD IDEA, BUT SHE DID
FEEL PUSHED BY THE PROGRESSIVES.
WHERE ELSE DO YOU SEE BEING
PUSHED BY PROGRESSIVE’S?
YOU COULD LOOK AT AFTER 2016,
WHAT DID BERNIE SANDERS DO?
HE GOT THE DNC TO CHANGE
EVERYTHING AND HOW IS THAT
WORKING OUT FOR THEM?
I THINK HER FRUSTRATION LAST
NIGHT WAS NOT ONLY JUST AT THE
PRESIDENT BUT ALSO AT HER
CAUCUS.
LOOKING AT THEM, THINKING, YOU
KNOW, I TOLD YOU THIS WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN AND NOW THEY ARE IN A
FIX AND THE PRESIDENT LOOKS LIKE
HE IS JUST GOING TO WALTZ RIGHT
BACK INTO THE WHITE HOUSE FOR A
SECOND TERM.
IT’S NOT GOING TO BE THAT EASY
BUT RIGHT NOW IT FEELS THAT WAY.
>> Greg: IT HASN’T GOTTEN ANY
WORSE FOR HIM AND IT’S GOTTEN
BETTER SINCE THEN.
I THINK WE HAVE SOME SOUND ON
TAPE OF MITCH McCONNELL
SMILING.
>> SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE AS SHE
REFUSES TO ACCEPT THIS
ACQUITTAL.
WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
PERHAPS SHE WILL TEAR UP THE
VERDICT LIKE SHE TORE UP THE
STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS.
THERE IS NO SIGN THESE ATTACKS
ON HER INSTITUTIONS WILL END
HERE.
WHATEVER POLICY DIFFERENCES WE
MAY HAVE, WE SHOULD ALL AGREE
THIS IS PRECISELY THE KIND OF
RECKLESSNESS, THE KIND OF
RECKLESSNESS THE SENATE WAS
CREATED TO STOP.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THAT?
>> Jesse: I THINK HE DID A
VERY GOOD JOB AS MAJORITY LEADER
IN THE SENATE AND HE DESERVES A
LOT OF CREDIT FOR GUIDING US
THROUGH.
I THINK THAT NANCY TRIED TO
BULLY HIM AND MITCH McCONNELL
IS NOT A MAN TO BE BULLIED AND
THAT IS VERY CLEAR.
THIS WAS NOT A CLOSED VOTE.
THEY WERE 20 VOTES SHORT OF
CONVICTION.
IT’S NOT EVEN IN THE REALM OF
POSSIBILITY.
>> Greg: IT WAS A PARTISAN
VOTE, WHICH IS THE WHOLE POINT
OF THE TWO-THIRDS.
>> Jesse: THEY NEEDED 67.
THEY GOT 20 VOTES LESS THAN
THAT.
YOU LOOK AT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION AND NOW THE
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL, TRUMP IS
CLEAN.
TRUMP IS AN INNOCENT MAN.
HE HAS BEEN FOUND GUILTY OF ZERO
CRIMES, AND JUAN, YOU SAID NOW
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
COMPLETELY CONVINCED THIS IS A
CORRUPT PRESIDENT.
I WOULD SAY THIS, I THINK THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AREN’T GOING TO
BELIEVE ANY ACCUSATION BY THE
DEMOCRATS AGAINST THE PRESIDENT
ANYMORE, ESPECIALLY IF IT COMES
FROM AN ANONYMOUS INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIAL LIKE THE LAST TWO
HOAXES HAVE COME FROM AND THAT
IS YOUR FAULT, BECAUSE HE DIDN’T
DO IT IN THE SUNLIGHT, YOU DID A
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS AND THAT IS
NOT THE WAY YOU TAKE OUT THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Juan: YOU KEEP ARGUING THE
PROCESS.
THE REASON I ASKED IF YOU WERE
PUMPED WAS BECAUSE THE MAN
BASICALLY GOT AWAY WITH IT.
THIS IS THE MAN ON FIFTH AVENUE
SHOOTING SOMEONE AND HIS
FOLLOWERS SAYING NOTHING.
AND AFTER MUELLER, WHERE THERE
WAS ALL THIS EVIDENCE, AGAIN, HE
SAID, I WAS EXONERATED.
IT’S UNBELIEVABLE.
WE CAN EXPECT TO SEE THAT.
I HEAR HE’S GOING TO GIVE A
STATEMENT TOMORROW.
I EXPECT HE WILL DO THAT AND
PLAY TO THE BASE AGAIN.
I WANT TO FINISH HERE.
HE SAYS BASICALLY WHAT
REPUBLICANS SAID TODAY, IS
DONALD TRUMP, IF YOU WANT TO DO
THIS AGAIN, IF YOU WANT TO REACH
OUT TO THE RUSSIANS, TO THE
CHINESE, IF YOU WANT TO BLAME
UKRAINIANS --
>> Jesse: CELL ALASKA!
>> Juan: DO WHATEVER YOU WANT,
BECAUSE YOU, DONALD TRUMP -- YOU
KNOW WHAT I HEARD TODAY?
DERSHOWITZ-IAN, WHICH MEANS
ANYTHING THE PRESIDENT DOES COME
AS LONG AS HE THINKS IT WILL
HELP HIM WIN ELECTION AND THAT
IS BEST FOR THE COUNTRY, THEN
IT’S OKAY.
THAT IS ALAN DERSHOWITZ, GO READ
THE QUOTE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAYS
CUSTOMER AGREED THE TRANSCRIPT.
>> Greg: NO, I READ IT.
IN THE INTEREST OF THE COUNTRY
THAT IT OBVIOUSLY HELPS HIM AND
REELECTION BID THAT’S EASY.
>> Juan: BECAUSE YOU’VE GOT TO
REELECT DONALD TRUMP HERE TO
>> Greg: YOU’RE ADDING THAT,
YOUR MIND READING.
YOU’RE ADDING A SECOND PART.
>> Juan: HE SAID IF THE
PRESIDENT BELIEVES HIS
REELECTION IS IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF THE COUNTRY, THEN
FINE, GO FOR IT.
>> Greg: IF YOU ARE
INVESTIGATING CORRUPTION OR
MAKING A MIDDLE EAST PEACE DEAL
THAT HAPPENS TO GET YOU
REELECTED, THAT DOESN’T NEGATE
IT.
>> Jesse: IT’S CALLED A MIXED
MOTIVE.
BUT I WANT TO ASK JUAN A QUICK
ANSWER.
IT IS TRUMP INNOCENT UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY?
>> Juan: EVERYONE IS INNOCENT
UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY BUT THAT IS
NOT A TRIAL.
THIS IS AN IMPEACHMENT.
>> Katie: JUAN KEEPS TALKING
ABOUT THE PROCESS, IT REALLY
SHOULDN’T MATTER BUT IN AMERICA
THE PROCESS IS EVERYTHING.
AND DEMOCRATS DIDN’T GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS IN THE HOUSE TO MAKE
SURE THEY HAD A SOLID CASE THAT
WAS READY TO SEND TO THE SENATE,
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHY
NANCY PELOSI WAS STEAMROLLED BY
HER CAUCUS FROM THE BEGINNING ON
THIS IMPEACHMENT PROCESS.
BUT WE ARE MOVING ON TO MORE OF
NANCY PELOSI’S BEHAVIOR IN JUST
A MINUTE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST TWEETED
ABOUT THE BOAT THIS AFTERNOON.
HE SAID, I WILL BE MAKING A
PUBLIC STATEMENT TOMORROW AT
12:00 P.M. FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
TO DISCUSS OUR COUNTRY’S VICTORY
ON THE IMPEACHMENT.
ALSO NOTE IN THE MEDIA AND
DEMOCRATS TOLD US IT WAS A
ROCK-SOLID CASE BUT THAT HAS
FALLEN FLAT.
>> WE HAVE A VERY ROCK-SOLID
CASE.
I THINK THE CASE, IF PRESENTED
TO A JURY WOULD BE A GUILTY
VERDICT IN 3 MINUTES FLAT.
>> HE HAS COMMITTED AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
SPEAK OF THE CONGRESS NOW KNOWS
THE PRESIDENT HAS COMMITTED
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES.
TO SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT IS
GUILTY.
HE IS GUILTY OF COMMITTING
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT IS
GUILTY.
EVERY FACT SHOWS THE PRESIDENT
IS GUILTY OF THESE IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSES.
>> Katie: DEMOCRATS MIGHT NOT
BE DONE.
HERE’S WHAT HAS IMPEACHMENT
MANAGER JERRY NADLER SAID
EARLIER.
>> TALKING ABOUT EVERYTHING.
EVERYTHING.
REMEMBER OUR INVESTIGATIONS ON
THE MUELLER REPORT THAT WE NEVER
FINISHED?
BECAUSE WE DIDN’T GET THE
WITNESSES.
WE WILL GET THOSE, WE WILL
CONTINUE WITH THAT.
>> Katie: IS THIS EVER GOING
TO END?
>> Dana: MITCH McCONNELL HAS
SAID SEVERAL TIMES, THERE IS
NOTHING MORE YOU CAN LEARN FROM
THE SECOND KICK OF A MULE.
IT’S LIKE TOUCHING THE HOT STOVE
IN YOUR LIFE, WHILE, GOSH, DON’T
EVER DO THAT AGAIN.
YOU DO IT ONCE AS A KID AND THEN
YOU ARE CAUTIOUS.
AGAIN, I STILL THINK
NANCY PELOSI, PART OF HER
FRUSTRATION HAS TO BE THAT SHE
GOT PUSHED INTO IT.
NOW THEY ALL HAVE TO SAY THE
SAME THING.
THEY ARE ALL TRYING TO SAY THE
EVERYONE IS IN THEIR CORNERS BUT
THE PRESIDENT IS ACTUALLY COMING
OUT ON TOP AND ALL THESE NUMBERS
THAT ARE IMPROVING, IT DOESN’T
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT BUT IT’S BEEN
PRETTY QUICKLY.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR SIX
MONTHS.
AMERICANS ARE SMART, AND I THINK
ONE, THEY WANT TO MOVE ON AND
THEY CAN FIGHT IT OUT AT THE
BALLOT BOX.
SIX MONTHS IS A LONG TIME,
ESPECIALLY RIGHT BEFORE AN
ELECTION AND NOW WE ARE NINE
MONTHS BEFORE.
YOU CAN HAVE A BABY BETWEEN NOW
AND THEN.
>> Greg: ARE YOU TELLING US
SOMETHING CUSTOMER XP DO I SAID,
YOU COULD HAVE A BABY.
>> Greg: I DO NOT HAVE A WOMB,
DANIADANA.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD KEEP
IMPEACHING HIM BECAUSE IT MAKES
THEM FEEL GOOD.
IT OCCUPIES THE DEMOCRATS’
HEADSPACE.
AND IT DOES MAKE TRUMP BETTER
BECAUSE HE LOVES A GOOD FIGHT.
IT’S BETTER THAN A FLINTSTONES
MULTIVITAMIN, GET HIM GOING.
AND IT MAKES HIM MORE
SYMPATHETIC.
IT DOES.
>> Juan: IS THAT RIGHT?
>> Jesse: TRUMP IS A VICTIM,
JUAN.
HE’S BEEN VICTIMIZED BY MILLIONS
OF DEMOCRATS IN INVESTIGATORS
FOR MANY YEARS AND THAT IS WHY
EVERYONE FEELS SORRY FOR THE
MAN.
ONLY HE COULD PUT UP WITH THAT
MUCH.
>> Juan: WHAT A MAN, WHAT A
MAN!
HE IS YOUR HERO.
BUT I MUST SAY, MITT ROMNEY, I
BELIEVE IT WAS A BIPARTISAN
VOTE.
>> Katie:>> Greg: ONE GUY COSMIC
>> Juan: WHAT HAPPENED TO
REPUBLICAN UNITY ON THAT FRONT?
I’M JUST SAYING, KYRSTEN SINEMA?
DEMOCRATS CUSTOMER DOUG JONES
COSMIC >> Katie: DOUG JONES IT
DOESN’T TO WORRY ABOUT IT.
I NEED A CAREER IN THE PARTY.
>> Juan: BUT WHAT HAPPENED TO
JOE MANCHIN?
REMEMBER?
PEOPLE DON’T VOTE ON PRINCIPLE,
JUST VOTE TO RETAIN YOUR POWER.
>> Greg: FIRST IT WAS A
BIPARTISAN PEER TO >> Juan:
THEY VOTED FROM THE HEART AS
OPPOSED TO POLITICALLY.
>> Jesse: WHY WOULD A DEMOCRAT
VOTE GUILTY?
THAT IS FROM THE HEART.
IT WENT TO REPUBLICAN VOTES
ACQUIT, THAT’S POLITICAL.
WHAT’S THE DIFFERENCE?
>> Juan: I’M GOING TO TELL YOU
WHAT REPUBLICANS HE SAID.
RUBIO, TO ME, COLLINS,
MURKOWSKI, AND ROMNEY ALL SAID
HIS ACTIONS WERE INAPPROPRIATE
AND EMBARRASS AING.
>> Dana: THEY ARE NOT THE ONLY
ONES WHO SAID THAT.
McCARTHY FROM THE BEGINNING
WAS LIKE, THE HOUSE SHOULD DO
THE CENSURE VOTE, WALK AWAY,
OTHERWISE THEY WILL WALK RIGHT
INTO IMPEACHMENT.
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS HAVE SAID
ALL THOSE THINGS BUT DON’T THINK
IT WAS IMPEACHABLE.
I DON’T THINK THAT IS SO OUT OF
THE REALM.
I THINK OVERSTATING THE ROMNEY
FACTOR OF THE ONE PERSON THAT
DECIDED TO VOTE ON ONE OF THE
ARTICLES TO CONVICT AND SAYING
THAT THAT BASICALLY SHATTERED
REPUBLICAN UNITY IS A LITTLE
BIT --
>> Juan: I DON’T THINK
SHATTERED.
I JUST SAID IT’S A FACT THAT
THERE IS A REPUBLICAN --
JUDGE NAPOLITANO, RIGHT HERE ON
FOX NEWS HAS BEEN SAYING ALL
ALONG, THIS GUY COMMITTED
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES.
>> Greg: HE WAS WRONG, I HATE
TO SAY IT.
>> Juan: IF THE POWER
EQUATION, GET ELECTED, PROTECT
YOURSELF.
>> Jesse: WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO TALK ABOUT AFTER THE TRIAL?
NOW THAT THIS IS OVER?
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO COMPLAIN
ABOUT?
>> Juan: I’M NOT COMPLAINING.
WHY WOULD I COMPLAIN?
>> Jesse: YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE
TO FOCUS ON THE DEMOCRATS AND
YOU DON’T WANT TO DO THAT
BECAUSE THAT IS A MESS OVER
THERE.
YOU IN THE MEDIA ARE NOW GOING
TO BE FORCED TO FOCUSED ON
THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
YOU DON’T HAVE IMPEACHMENT
ANYMORE, YOU DON’T HAVE ANOTHER
TRUMP SCANDAL RIGHT NOW THAT
YOU’RE COOKING UP.
YOU HAVE TO FOCUS ON THE
DEMOCRAT PRIMARY, AND THAT IS
GOING TO BE A NIGHTMARE.
>> Katie: DO YOU REALLY THINK
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO COME UP
WITH SOME OTHER SCANDAL?
>> Jesse: THEY’RE GOING TO
HAVE TO COME UP WITH THEM AND
QUICK.
>> Juan: IT LOOK, IT’S STILL A
FACT.
HALF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THINK
THIS GUY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
IMPEACHED.
>> Dana: THAT WAS TAKEN BEFORE
IMPEACHMENT WAS EVEN STARTED.
>> Juan: NO, THAT IS WHAT
PUSHED NANCY PELOSI AND MODERATE
DEMOCRATS TO BACK IMPEACHMENT.
>> Katie: SHE HAD TO GO BACK
ON HER WORD AND SAY IMPEACHMENT
HAD TO BE BIPARTISAN FROM THE
BEGINNING.
DEMOCRATS JOINED REPUBLICANS IN
THE HOUSE TO VOTE AGAINST IT AND
HERE WE ARE NOW WITHOUT THE
RESULTS THAT YOU THINK YOU
SHOULD HAVE BASED ON WHAT YOU
THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT.
BUT IT WAS POLITICAL FROM THE
BEGINNING AND THE REFLECTION OF
THE IMPEACHMENT POLLS REFLECT
EXACTLY HOW PEOPLE COME DOWN,
WHAT THEY’RE VOTING ON AN
MOMENTUM ON THIS HAS BEEN
TOWARDS THE PRESIDENT FROM THE
START.
I MEAN, THE POLL NUMBERS, THE
BIPARTISANSHIP FROM THE FRONT
END, WE THAT HAS BEEN ON HIS
SIDE.
>> Greg: WHEN I WAS WATCHING
THE END OF THIS VOTE, THEY ALL
STARTED TO GET IN A FRENZY
AGAIN, DID YOU SEE THAT?
THEY STARTED THANKING PEOPLE,
THEY SHOULD THANK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FOR SITTING THROUGH THIS
CIRCUS AND THANK US FOR BEING SO
COGENT IN OUR ANALYSIS AND BEING
RIGHT ALL ALONG.
I DIDN’T HEAR A THANK YOU FROM
THEM AND I AM PERSONALLY
OFFENDED.
>> Jesse: I ACTUALLY DO WANT
TO SAY I WAS RIGHT ALL ALONG.
WE TOLD YOU FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING THAT THIS WAS A PHONE
CALL, THESE WERE WEAK ARTICLES
AND THERE WAS GOING TO BE AN
ACQUITTAL BUT ALL YOU DID WAS
WHINE THE WHOLE TIME AND YOU
DIDN’T LISTEN TO ALL WE SAID AND
THE FACT THAT MITT ROMNEY
LISTENED TO A BRILLIANT LEGAL
PRESENTATION AND HE IS A SMART
GUY, AND HE CAME DOWN ON THE
SIDE OF GUILTY MAKES ME THINK I
DON’T THINK HE WAS REALLY OPEN
TO HEARING THE LEGAL ANALYSIS
BECAUSE WHY WOULD YOU VOTE FOR
MORE WITNESSES IF YOU WERE STILL
OPEN-MINDED AND THINKING ABOUT,
MAYBE THIS ISN’T A CLOSED CASE?
THEN YOU GET NO WITNESSES AND
YOU VOTE TO CONVICT?
IT DOESN’T ADD UP.
>> Juan: IT WAS A STRONG CASE
BUT YOU HAVE JOHN BOLTON SITTING
OUT THERE.
IF YOU HAD DOCUMENTS, EVEN
TODAY, MORE DOCUMENTS COMING OUT
THAT INDICATE THE PRESIDENT WAS
INTENT ON USING THIS INFLUENCE
FOR HIS POLITICAL AND PERSONAL
GAIN.
WHY NOT?
>> Katie: THE ACCUSATIONS WILL
NEVER END.
YOUR CONTINUING AUNT, USING
JOHN BOLTON, MAYBE, IF.
>> Juan: NO, BUT JOHN BOLTON
IS SITTING OUT THERE AND HE HAS
DIRECT KNOWLEDGE.
>> Jesse: YOU KNOW WHO ELSE IS